tu avance rapidement il resterait moins
ça
à la fois
il est mort avec 1 heure
non oui il est mort cet homme
j'avais plus qu'assez vous moi nous tous
on est tous là crever pour qu'il reste
de riches
tu sais qui fusille de déserteurs
deux des fugitifs à toi ne vais pas
mourir pour que les riches puissent
vendre leurs côtés c'est pour ça qu'on
fluide aussi
aucun homme ne doit dire un autre homme
pourquoi il doit vivre ni pourquoi il
doit mourir n'est pas la patience de
chercher cinq ou six déserteurs caché
dans le marais c'est vrai
qu'on les pende
à
on se bat pour nos enfants et pour les
enfants de nos enfants
à partir de ce jour déclarant que les
terres au nord du marais de pascagoula
deviendront l'état libre de kyoto
ce sont de pauvres fermiers des
déserteurs qui franchement monsieur
n'ont pas grand chose à perdre
le vent est en train de tourner
evra pas le battre cette fois
ya tant d'autres raisons de se battre
je dois doucement tu es bien
c'est l'heure je sais que tu as peur le
thème est qu'ils aiment dieu tu sais je
suis tellement garçon tu vas pas mourir
tu vas pas mourir
tu as pas bien
je tiens à apporter quelque chose ouais
bat combat on va combard combat le m se
prononce comme un n 10 pages des combats
combat mais pourquoi y ait un c est la
fin ça arrive souvent en fait combattent
il ya aussi combattants là là un secret
secrète
ce crédit est l'histoire du m
le n 2 20 m de ventes belle-beille toi